hey youtubers is Charlie so exciting
stuffs happening Game of Thrones has
started casting season six and we have
descriptions for a bunch of characters
just to put things into perspective
though they cast about 25 new big
characters for season 5 so this is like
a fraction of that what I'm gonna do is
just a breakdown of the names that they
lists most of them don't have names
usually whenever show's cast big
characters they try to use fake names to
throw people off the descriptions for
the characters are solid though and they
point to some some very big characters
from the books being cast and the good
news is is that Comic Con is just a
couple weeks away so they'll do their
yearly casting video and we'll find out
who at least like six or seven - these
really big people are just give up for
spoilers if you haven't finished season
5 yet and a new round of the giveaway
starts now all you have to do to enter
is be a subscriber and leave a comment
on this video it's just a $20 Amazon
gift card so here we go starting with
the pirate I already did a year on
Greyjoy video for this that that's who
everyone thinks this new pirate
character is I know there are a lot of
Ironborn fans out there that were bummed
they got cut out of season 5 it seems
like even if they cut out a lot of that
plot we will at least get your uncle a
joy so that'll be a little bit of
Ironborn stuff if you haven't seen that
video I did I'll put a link in the
description but moving along there's a
father age 52 60s he's one of the
greatest soldiers in Westeros humorless
martinet severe and intimidating really
the big thing here is that it said that
he's centrally involved in a
protagonists storyline so the big theory
here is that this is randyll Tarly this
is Sam wells father Samwell and Gilly as
of the end of season five are on their
way to old town which is very near horn
Hill where Sam's families from the
humorless description just fits Sam's
father to a tee the way he described him
to Jon back in season one then there's a
couple of their family characters
associated with that father there's a
mother a son and a daughter and it
sounds like they're just casting the
rest of Sam wells family samwell's
mother is Melissa Florent his younger
brother is Dickon remember he's the one
that Sam wills father is supposed to
like more because he's more of a warrior
there is a sister listed but I don't
remember Samwell ever talking about a
sister in the books so she could be an
original creation of the show the show
adds a lot of original characters if you
remember during season 5 Stannis
actually spoke very highly of randyll
Tarly when he was talking to Sam well
even though Sam's father
fought against him so that tells you
what a fierce warrior he is so moving
along there's a new priest that's said
to be in his 40s or 50s a gruff ex
soldier who found religion a no-nonsense
rural priest who ministers to the poor
of the countryside
he's a salt of the earth man who has
weathered many battles even if they
changed the name he sounds like septa
and mayor bald from the books you know
everybody start your gravedigger
theorycrafting now no idea what plot
he's gonna be associated with in the
books maybe Brienne and Podrick we'll
see if you don't know who the
gravedigger is there's just like this
mass fan theory that the Hound is still
alive and living under a different name
but then we have a priestess in her 20s
or 30s any ethnicity she's beautiful
intense big magnetic there were some
casting sides that were floating around
for a new red priestess in old volantis
so that might be who this is it doesn't
sound like anyone specific from the
books but just make a mental note the
show is slowly casting more and more
people associated with the red God I
mean it only makes sense if the war for
the dawn is endgame we have to learn
more about his religion and we can only
do that through more red priests right
now we only know Melisandre and Thoros
Amir and we haven't seen thorough sand
forever so moving along then there's
three boys that look like they might be
part of a flashback there's a large boy
in actor who's ten or twelve but Plank
seven or eight described as a clever boy
who seems too large for his age big and
tall but not bad then a 12 year old boy
with brown hair blue eyes he needs to
use a northern accent that that means
he's gonna be from the north in the show
like the north of Westeros he has scenes
where he has to spar with a wooden sword
then there's a seven-year-old boy with
dark brown hair a narrow face and green
eyes he also has a northern accent
sparged with a wooden sword so the best
theory is is that this is going to be a
Ned Stark flashback in the godswood of
Winterfell Ned Stark is a child they
started season 5 with the Cersei
flashbacks oh so of course the show is
gonna do more flashbacks just avoid like
very definite spoilers I'm gonna avoid
talking about the character that does
have this flashback but if you know who
that is
just please use spoiler tags if you want
to talk about it next characters there's
two very dokey sounding characters with
names that aren't from the books they
sound like they're gonna be part of this
Daenerys storyline early in this season
she just got taken by them in the finale
so of course we're gonna see a bunch of
Dothraki
stuff in the first couple of episodes
then there's a band of outlaws that
could be someone from the books it could
be an original creation of the show they
all have names that aren't from the
books the leader is named Lachlan in the
description reads that they've turned on
the people in the land they've sworn to
protect
one of them's called Bauer he's a
powerless servant who's numb to the
horror of those he serves all of them
are supposed to have northern English
accents when I think of northern English
I think of Walder Frey but there's also
a lot of actors that are supposed to be
from Northern Ireland which is where the
North scenes are filmed so this is
probably happening somewhere in the
north
the only real notable outlaw bands that
we've seen on the show so far are the
Brotherhood without banners which is you
know Thoreau Samir that was back during
season two and then Locke's group which
was kind of a stand-in for the brave
companions so I don't think that this
new group is either one of those this
next one is actually really awesome it
sounds like a flashback character he's
supposed to be a legendary fighter a man
in his 30s or 40s who is a great
swordsman and a paragon of knighthood
he carries a famous sword meaningful
Irian sword the show is seeking a very
impressive swordsman for the role the
best in Europe so the actor that they
want to cast needs to be an amazing
swordsman he'll be filming a week's
worth of fighting scenes for season six
role
there's no ethnicity or race specified
the leading theory right now is that
this is Arthur Dayne in a flashback his
famous Valyrian sword is called dawn
it's a two-handed great sword just like
Ned Stark's ice Arthur Dayne is one of
the few characters that other characters
on the show and in the books have
acknowledged as being a better fighter
than they were Barristan Selmy calls him
out as a better fighter
and if Barristan Selmy says you're a
good fighter that means you're like
Jesus with a sword - my opinion right
now there are no living Westerosi
characters that meet this description
that's why I think it's another
flashback so here's where it gets even
more interesting Arthur Dayne died
during Robert's rebellion at the Tower
of joy he fell while he was guarding
Lyanna Stark but it was when Ned Stark
and Howland Reed came to rescue her
Howland Reed landed the killing blow so
the tinfoil Theory to this is that we
could get a tower of joy flashback I've
already done a video all about Lyanna
Stark that kind of explains what goes on
at the Tower of joy so I'll put a link
in the description but but basically Ned
Stark Howland Reed found outbreak
our Targaryen was keeping Lyanna stark
at the tower joy went to get her
Rhaegar had to lead to join the war
rebellion but he left his closest friend
Arthur Dayne behind to protect her ned
referred to him as the finest knight he
ever knew and after he died he took his
Valyrian sword he took dawn to star fall
to his sister ashara dayne one of the
early theories for Jon Snow's parents
were that Ned Stark with his father in
ashara dayne was his mother Ned was just
a star Fault to return Arthur Dayne
sword to his family I of course back the
R + L equals J theory of Jon Snow's
parentage but you guys can watch my
Lyanna stark video and form your own
opinions
moving along there's a couple more
really big characters that are looking
for from Northern Ireland which is where
they film the scenes in the north so
just more characters from the north
there are two big lords there looking
for four different castles
the first is a savage warrior who's
supposed to be huge like really big so
he's probably gonna be small John umber
his father is great John number who we
have seen on the show the other Lord is
supposed to be ruthless and calculating
a frightening Lord that rules a Bassel
household with a castle stronghold the
other big place could be white Harbor so
they could be doing white Harbor and the
last hearth which is where house numbers
from there are a couple other big places
in the north we haven't seen yet we
haven't seen the karhold yet we haven't
seen Deepwood Motte so there are a
number of places this could be but I
definitely think the umbers for that you
know the giant character they're looking
for and that's pretty much it for like
the big characters obviously like that's
a lot of people so we're not gonna see
all of those in the comic-con video just
the biggest ones that's about four weeks
away comic-con is like the second week
in July I will be there
I'll get footage of the panel all that
stuff so no worries I haven't done any
comic-con videos yet it's just it's not
quite close enough so when we get closer
to that I'll start doing previews of
like all the stuff I'm gonna be doing
them on there but the characters I'm
most excited for hopefully you know if
some of these theories pan out or you're
on Greyjoy Arthur Dayne young Ned Stark
and Sam wells family here's my big
question for you guys if the show is
going to be doing Arthur Dayne in the
flashback do you think that it's going
to tell us something new about Robert's
rebellion and maybe something to do with
Jon Snow's parentage just because this
caste news came kind of suddenly I'm
going to move my resurrection video to
Sunday and
I'll do a Q&A just like I normally do on
Monday so the giveaway will just stay
open until I post that Q&A video I'll
just remind everyone when I post that
next video so why you guys wait for all
that stuff to post you can click here to
learn all about lyanna stark's history
and you can click here for my season six
predictions thank you so much for
watching everybody let's high five I'll
see you guys tonight